♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est très difficile de
s'exprim q quand on... quand
on a un lieu tellement cher.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est une relation...
émotionnelle avec la médina.
La médina, c'est notre mémoire.
- Je suis chaque jour de
la médina. Quand je prends mon
café, je pense jamais le prendre
à l'extérieur. Souvent, je viens
de la médina.
- De l'amour à profusion
pour une cité qui incarnait
la puissance des siècles durant.
Une ville fortifiée et un port,
plaque tournante du commerce
avec l'Afrique jusqu'à la fin
du 19e siècle.
Ici, Juifs, Chrétiens
et Musulmans cohabitent
paisiblement depuis la nuit
des temps.
Aujourd'hui, la médina
d'Essaouira, joyau du patrimoine
mondial de l'Unesco, attire
les touristes par dizaines
de milliers.
C'est aussi et surtout
le coeur d'une communauté.
Mais cette forteresse pourrait
bientôt avoir les pieds
dans l'eau, conséquence
des changements climatueues.
- Il se peut que la mer vienne
couler dans la ruelle. Voilà.
Oui, oui.
- urur Aziz et ses amis,
trois enseignants à la retraite,
la médina d'Essaouira
n'a plus aucun secret.
Ils sont nés ici, ils ont grandi
ici et y passent maintenant une
grande partie de leurs journées.
(rires)
Dans ces rues autrefois habitées
par des Phéniciens, des Romains
et des Portugais, ils oublient
la notn n du temps.
Ils papotent avec les copains
et prennent le café.
Pour Saïd, perdre sa médina
adorée serait un grand choc.
- Quand j'ai perdu l'un
de nos parents, c'est une
catastrophe...
- C'est l'ancien quartier juif
d'Essaouira.
- Car ils savent que
les infiltrations d'eau et
les inondations enent être
sans merci.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ce quartier de la ville
en a déjà été victime.
- Il y a les infiltrations de
la mer. Ce qui fait que beaucoup
de maisons sont devenues
instables. Et il y avait en plus
des inondations qui ont commencé
en 1996, qui ont fait beaucoup
de familles qui sont déménéeées,
qui sont relogées.
- Aziz rappelle que les
autorités n'ont pas eu le choix
d'exproprier les quelque
3000 résidents du quartier
et de détruire les maisons
fragilisées.
- Ça fait mal au coeur, parce
que j'ai visitlele quartier
toute ma vie. C'est un très beau
quartier d'ailleurs, hein.
Et de le voir comme ça,
ça fait mal au coeur, hein.
- Depuis quelques années,
l'État fait d'importants travaux
dans le port et dans la médina,
ce qui permettra de reconstruire
cette portion de la ville.
Les plus jeunes aussi,
comme Amine,n n professeur
de 33 ans, craignent le pire.
- Il y avait le photographe ici.
- Amine nous montre le riad
où il est né.
- C'est dans cette maison?
- Oui, c'est dans cette maison.
J'ai vécu au deuxième étage.
- Il considère égoistste les pas
développés qui continuent
d'exploiter les énergies
fossiles.
- Je crois qu'ils s'en foutent
du devenir des gens, des autres.
On peut avoir des alternatives
au pétrole. Pourquoi l'utiliser?
Pourquoi l'extraire? Extraire
du prorole d'une région qui est,
comme on dit...
J'ai perdu...
- Riche et capable de
diversifier...
- Oui, je perds les mots.
Je suis un peu ému.
- Le maire d'Essaouira est
conscient que la préservation
de la médina demandera
énormément de moyens.
- Sam m alaykoum.
- Déjà, face aux assauts répétés
d'une mer déchaînée,
la muraille s'érode.
- Il y a des efforts qui sont
faits par l'État. Il y a
des efforts qui sont faits
par les... par la ville,
par les autorités, par les élus,
malgré le peu de moyens qu'on a.
Donc, je pense que la ville
a besoin d'aide, le Maroc
également a besoin d'aide
dans ce sens.
- Tarik Ottmani voudrait bien
offrir un tour guidé de
sa médina aux grands dirigeants
des nations les plus polluantes.
- J'aimerais les emmener faire
un tour et voir toute cette
population qui vit, c'est des
des petites mains. Vous allez
fae e un tour dans la médina,
vous allez voir, vous allez vite
comprendre que ces gens-là
ne se soucient même pas de ça.
Là c'est la population la plus
menacée. Donc moi, je les
emmènerai d'abord voir ce que
cette menace représente
pour pour leur vie,
pour leur famille.
Les petites mains dont parle
le maire sont comme celles
d'Hassan, un ébéniste qui
travaille le tuya.
Vous voyez la médina, elle est
toute inondée.
- Hmm-hmm.
- L'artisan n'avait aucune idée
que sa médina était menacée.
"Je suis désolé d'apprendre
tout ça. J'ignorais tout de ce
scénario. Je ne m'attendais pas
à voir ce genre d'image.
Hassan est déconcerté.
"Je ne peux pas vivre en dehss
de la médina. Même quand
je voyage, je n'ai qu'une chose
en tête : revenir ici
à la médina.
♪ ♪ ♪
Si la médina d'Essaouira
n'est à nulle autre pareille,
sa situation est loin d'être
unique.
À moins d'un sérieux coup de
barre pour limiter les émissions
de GES et d'efforts concertés
pour les protéger,
une cinquantaine d'autres sites
classés en Afrique sont
en péril, menacés par une dame
nature qui s'affole.
- C'est un patrimoine
international, c'est un bijou,
c'est un patrimoine
de l'humanité.
- Des joyaux du patrimoine
mondial, mais aussi des colosses
aux pieds d'argile.